there's been a lot of talk surrounding
specter and meltdown the names given to
vulnerabilities that affect practically
every processor made in the past two
decades without taking a deep dive into
the technical details the short of it is
that they could allow an attacker to
pluck what was previously considered
protected data from your CPUs cache this
includes passwords encryption keys and
other sensitive information trust us you
don't want this information getting out
to the wrong hands
[Music]
security researchers from Google's
project zero team discovered the
vulnerabilities in 2017 and disclosed
them to the public in early 2018
unfortunately there is no quick fix
as Spector and meltdown are part of the
fundamental design of most processors in
effect this means that your PC is most
likely affected the good news is that
there are no known exploits in the wild
based on specter and meltdown however at
least two cybersecurity firms have
identified proof-of-concept
samples based on these vulnerabilities
nevertheless it's a safe bet that
attackers will eventually attempt to
leverage the specter and meltdown in the
meantime there are some things you can
do to protect yourself the biggest one
is to make sure your operating system
has the latest updates
Microsoft is pretty aggressive about
doling out automatic updates to Windows
so most users can sit back and let the
OS patch itself if you want to be
proactive however manually check for
updates to make sure you're fully
patched the same goes for Linux Chrome
OS and Mac OS spectre and meltdown
affect all operating systems not just
Windows you should also make sure your
internet browsers are all up to date
Google recently updated its Chrome
browser to version 64 and it
incorporates patches to protect against
specter and meltdown to make sure you're
running the latest build click on the
three vertical dots in the upper right
corner and go to help and then about
Google Chrome this will tell you what
version you're running and initiate an
update if there is one in chrome 63 and
later there's also an experimental
feature called site isolation that is
disabled by default turning it on offers
additional protection against certain
types of web attacks based on meltdown
inspector though it increases Chrome's
memory usage by around 10 to 20 percent
if you're ok with that you can turn the
feature on by typing in this address
into the URL bar then scroll down to
strict site isolation and press the
enable button another way is to type
this address into the URL bar
there are no special flights in Firefox
edge Opera or Safari however you should
make sure you're running the latest
version of each in Firefox open up the
menu and navigate to help then about
Firefox updating opera is summer click
on the menu and select about opera both
edge and Safari are updated by their
respective os's Windows and Mac OS one
other thing you can do is check for BIOS
updates for your motherboard so
motherboard burners have begun releasing
updated firmware specifically to protect
against Spectre in meltdown you can
check for new bios releases by going to
your motherboards manufactures website
and either looking up your motherboard
model or navigate to the support section
given that this is all rather new it's a
good idea to do some research before
applying a BIOS update specifically
you'll also want to see if other users
have reported any problems with the new
BIOS if one is available also you should
only attempt this if you are comfortable
updating biases the on staying up to
date standards apply avoid sharing your
sides of the web
be wary of clicking on shady links and
emails and instant messages and keep
your antivirus software turned on for
complete step-by-step instructions head
on over to the article on gamespot comm
thanks for watching
[Music]
you